grande bleue en surface teinté de rouge
en profondeur en méditerranée le golf de
cassis regorge de boues rouges rejeté
par une usine alteo depuis saint quentin
l'industriel n'a eu de cesse de
désinformer public tout simplement pour
gagner du temps pour pouvoir continuer à
déverser ses déchets dans
l'environnement alteo anciennement
pechiney depuis plus d'un siècle à
gardanne dans les bouches du rhône
cette usine extrait de l'aluminé à
partir d'une roche la bauxite
les boues rouges c'est tout simplement
leurs résidus de la fabrication de la
les mines
après qu'on l'a extraite de la bauxite
avant les déchets étaient stockés sur
terre mais les quantités sont colossales
alors en 1966 lusine a commencé à
déverser des boues rouges en mer elle
arrive à sept kilomètres au large de
cassis à 320 mètres de profondeur sans
risques selon une étude gouvernementale
menée à l'époque il n'y a aucune
possibilité de contamination par
l'intermédiaire par l'intermédiaire de
victor ivan et de notre part les boues
rouges ne sont pas constitués comme vous
savez de substances toxiques pour autant
la population locale s'inquiète une voix
de poids s'ajoute à la contestation
celle d'alain bombard biologiste marin
il est absolument certain que cette
pollution se révélera par la suite
dangereuse 27 ans plus tard en 1993 le
temps donne raison aux opposants au fond
des mers une épaisse boue rouge
plus de corail ni d'herbe sous marine
est presque plus de poids saut c'est une
pollution mécanique par ensevelissement
on voit par exemple si une grange corail
qui est morte parce qu'il a été
les polis pour été envahie par cette
fine pellicule de de boue rouge
en 1996 un arrêté préfectoral stipule
que l' usine devra mettre fin au rejet
de boue en mer à partir de 2015
l'entreprise met en place une autre
solution en 2007
le filtrage la partie liquide et rejetés
en mer
la partie solide et revaloriser côté mer
l'entreprise obtient dérogations sur
dérogation
elle fait valoir son poids économique et
son rôle dans l'emploi local en 2016
elle est autorisée à rejeter en mer
c'est nicky de filtrer jusqu'en 2022
les opposants manifestent devant le
ministère de l'écologie et met en avant
la toxicité de serge et les poissons
étaient contaminés dix à mille fois plus
que ce qu'annonçait l'industriel
notamment pour ce qui est du mercure de
l'arsenic et l'échéance de 2020 deux a
finalement été avancée
halte et on ne peut désormais plus
déverser ses liquides dans la mer sans
se mettre aux normes environnementales
[Musique]